so I put out a post on my story asking
for JB's and I had five people message
back so within eight hours I had 75k
dming me what was it that Drew to rent
direct controlling the property without
owning it it gives you a lot of power
some people are afraid to do business
because they're worried of failing
you're only fail when you stop tell me
what deals you've done and how much
money you're making in Cambridge I've
got three apartments two Studios one two
bed if you're not confident in your
business why would anybody else be so on
average a month what is your business
term I'm profiting just under 3K pretty
much all the safeties in the UK can work
for sa how old do you reckon you'll be
by the time you're a millionaire
[Music]
you were one of the young guys to join
the academy you were like around about
18. I think by the time I joined the
Academy I think I just turned 19. yeah
or turned 19 during the academy year and
I remember one of your first rent to
rent calls when we were at the program
and it was terrible it was woeful oh
[__] yeah I even remember how bad your
your call was I think what did you say
when you first rang the landlord you
remember yeah it was it was something
along the lines of I've got an
interesting proposition for you or
something like that and they were just
like uh straight away checked out yeah
that's another thing as well when you're
selling and property is sales I think
that people have already decided if they
want to do business with you before you
even actually tell them the offer and
this has been shown like when I stop
people in the streets when I was in Hyde
Park and I was saying would you be
interested in and the next line was
literally having a free house and I was
trying to give away a free house and
I'll stop people in the street but I
said excuse me sir would you be
interested no I'm not interested and
it's like they don't even know what you
you about to say and it's the same when
you're trying to sell joint ventures
you've raised how much have you raised
in the last in the last 24 hours okay so
in the last so I put out a post on my
story asking for JB's and the minimum
requirement was 15K and I had five
people message back so within about
eight hours I had 75k dming me damn and
now I've just got it and what are you
gonna do with that 75k so that's
hopefully
gonna go towards a luxury essay that's a
big place it's quite cool tell me about
it what is it sure so um I don't want to
be too specific because there's still oh
because you've got something yeah yeah
yeah and as we say never be ease until
you got the keys exactly but it is it's
quite cool it can sleep a lot of people
but it's also got space for corporate
events which means the York Community
doesn't have to rely on overnight stays
it can also be like daytime bookings
which will hopefully hopefully boost up
the occupancy rate what's it what's the
daytime well if a business needs a space
to do certain events because sometimes
they do social events sometimes it is
specific corporate stuff right they can
either use the Garden area or you turn
the downstairs area into a space where
you can fit 10 15 20 people and do
corporate events right so it's like a
rent to rent but it's more a commercial
type well it's not it's not not just
that so it'll have the commercial aspect
but then it'll also be your normal essay
yeah yeah like I hope like a mini Hotel
yeah exactly love that bro yeah fist
pump for that brother so tell me tell me
about what was it that made you get into
property because you're quite Young when
we first met you 18
um what was it that gave you that desire
to get into property so I did my a
levels during covet and it was awful it
was really bad obviously it was hard on
the teachers because they can teach
properly but I was just not clicking
with college anymore so my greatest jobs
and everything but by that point I was
already looking into like trading other
investing stocks and all that and
obviously you go down certain rabbit
holes on YouTube and see your videos I
just started looking at property and I
watched enough videos to decide that
that's the best route for me did some
other training and then jumped in your
training and what would you say because
when I started out to you and for me
everyone was like what are you doing but
I don't know if the cook just changed
slightly because they're like Gary
vaynerchuk and you're from from your
face expressions no but like has the
culture changed a little bit are people
more accepting now to entrepreneurship
and like is it kind of almost cool to be
an entrepreneur it certainly wasn't when
I started or did you get the same kind
of brick wall from your family and
friends that I got I think now if you
talk now it is
cool cool thing to do because I think
the hustle
culture the side hustle culture that's
really picked up a lot but at that time
I didn't have much support I think
people are thinking like what are you
doing yeah it's a bit weird who said
that everyone but everyone yeah family
and friends they weren't they weren't
particularly supportive at the start but
kind of in a way don't blame him because
you're scared of what you don't know and
for them they just didn't I was doing
yeah and people can say they understand
older people they don't say they
understand property but
rent to rent is a
pretty Modern Property investment
strategy which for the older Generations
that just don't I don't understand we
parents skeptical yeah 100 already yeah
are you living with them dealing with
them yeah that's all of them are you
still
I lived at home until I was like 20. I
live with my mom again it's like when
you're living at home and you're a
teenager and you're going out on
viewings and looking at buying hotels
you know there's also sometimes you can
feel you know the um the talk about
imposter syndrome where it's like am I
really qualified to do this did you have
any of that do you have any of that no
are you an imposter no
now now because
I've proven myself to myself right other
people
I know I'm on it you know what I mean I
know I'm about it so I don't have
imposter syndrome but at the start there
was a lot of skepticism and
I think you're seeing more as just a
little project or hobby rather than
actual business oh bless him he's doing
this little thing on the side of his
yeah yeah and which is understandable
because
it's not serious until it gets serious
isn't it is it serious now oh 100 tell
me what deals you've done and how much
money you're making if you don't mind so
I've got in Cambridge I've got three
apartments two Studios one two bed the
two bed I've just got and it's really
cool it's got hot tub and a arcades
machine yeah nice all about the USP yeah
yeah it's gonna call it I've just got a
21 night booking for it the day it went
live I think the following day I got two
bookings was titled 6K so on average a
month what is your business turning
right now
16k ish okay 16 Grand 16 on average 16
18 Grand and one of that is your
whatever that's profit so I'm profiting
just under 3K Okay cool so that's like a
full-time salary were you working before
were you used to college I was I was
working at Iceland and I didn't enjoy it
I remember
you I remember and you were saying to me
like I have to get out of this but see
by that time I had my first essay sudo
essay yeah so I was I was itching to get
more and I I got a rental HMO which
unfortunately I lost it because of techy
issues but I was I was itching to get
out and just do it full time because I
already had a couple deals at that point
but yeah it was probably the environment
more than anything because I wasn't
surrounded by people who were on the
same path great people still mates with
a lot of them but there just weren't
business mindset which didn't really
give me much to it how do you break into
a new environment of people that get it
that are on the same path how do you
break into that the first thing for
people if I'd say no experienced social
media all the way because that how many
billions of people are on Instagram
right there's so much content on YouTube
before you even talk to people face to
face just clue up and stuff online
because I I always say the first
education you you should do for business
is YouTube University right so much
content yeah like listening to this
podcast and getting clued up on the
lingo and understanding what a rent to
rent is and how to speak to landlords
and then when you are in the right room
and you are in front of landlords and
you are in front of investors you're
able to kind of hold your own at least
in a conversation 100 and so clue
yourself up on YouTube and then
if you're trying to go into a space just
message people on Instagram like I sound
like an influence right now but I get
quite a lot of DMS um from property
people and from non-profit people
talking about business
and I'm always happy to answer and help
people and that's the same with a lot of
others as well before you go to
networking events which are brilliant
which are key very important just talk
to people on Instagram like all their
pictures like their stories because I I
recognize people who are constantly
liking my stuff and I mean in person I
feel like oh yeah that's him and I'll go
chat to him and then I'll I'll be much
happier to give him my value my time
because I see him liking my stories all
the time what was the first event you
ever went to where you were like okay I
I get it it's clicking in place the
first event I went to it was the online
pin event in Cambridge
and I remember I was definitely the
youngest person because I was 18 at the
time I was the youngest person and I
said that I was I was like oh yeah I'm
18 and what I want to get into property
and then people are it's awesome they're
really supportive and I remember asking
so how do I find property deals and
everyone just started laughing because
obviously like that's the obvious
question that's what everyone wants to
know but I'd say just networking events
are so good basically just like in
person Supermarket you know in the sense
where you have sources you'll have
management companies you have people
with money if you talk to the right
people you can get everything you need
so talk me through then how you got your
first deal like how did you go as I say
from this kid asking silly questions on
online networking events on Zoom
watching videos how did you go from that
to a professional property investor I
was on spare room calling landlords and
spare room I don't think it's the best
one for sa because obviously it's spare
room so it's mainly for hmos but there
was a studio apartment on it and I just
called up and I was like hi blah blah
blah I did my Spiel one thing I made
sure to do was not sound like a
salesperson because yeah on earlier when
you mentioned my first call that that
you remembered which was really bad I
sounded like a salesperson hi it's Ben
here like you know yeah sounding like
yeah I'm an insurance company right
don't do that yeah because that
instantly shows that you're trying to
sell to someone like selling is in the
words but it's in the tone and how you
present yourself so I didn't sound like
a sales person
and he liked it he actually had a rental
company before
who had to stop to the covered which
completely stopped their business so he
was happy for me to to come on board and
you agreed what to rent in the property
talk to me as well I was going to say to
you like if you were explaining the
concept the business of rent to rent
which is what you've you've been quite
successful at as well as other stuff how
would you summarize it to a skeptical
parent what is it to put it very very
simply is a company subletting a
property when they rent it out on
short-term stays or as an HMO Roomba
room so you rent it and then you rent it
out for a higher amount why would the
landlord not do that themselves
some landlords just can't be bothered
because quite a lot of landlords that I
encounter are older you know especially
in Cambridge like they brought it
decades ago held on to it it's now
quadrupled in value they just can't be
bothered so for example my rent to rent
company we cover 200 pounds of
Maintenance a month
if 200 quids of Maintenance happened
with an agent you'd also have all the
fees on top of that so lots of added up
expenses so for uh landlords it's ease
really how do you as some a teenager
that's working Iceland
get a landlord to actually trust you and
you've taken on several of the of these
properties yeah is it with the same
landlord or different
um two with the same landlord actually
um and obviously he trusted me enough to
give me his second which is good okay
but trust is really important because a
property is generally speaking a
person's biggest asset and they want it
in good hands right how do you get them
to trust you so how do you get through
referencing when you're Iceland on 1200
a month when you're a teenager you live
in a hunt so firstly you've got to
present yourself well
like don't don't give them reasons to be
skeptical if you're coming in like uh
hello my my name is Ben I'm actually 18
by the way but I would like to rent your
property my chance right because you're
giving them opportunities to uh to be
against you if you call them being
confident knowing your [__] not
stuttering which obviously takes time
they're not gonna think you're any
different to any of the other
Professionals in the market that's true
that's true so I get I guess yeah they
don't know how old you are no they don't
know that you're living at home and the
only time I've been asked that is when
I've initially brought up age then after
that you've gotta know your business
you've got a know what you're providing
and be confident because if you're not
confident in your business why'd anybody
else be I know I can look after my
landlord's properties I know I can look
after my guests
and that's a good enough reason for me
for them to
essentially invest in my business yeah
that's that's a good point how did you
justify investing in yourself in the
training education again as a teenager
at Iceland how did you raise the finance
and how did you justify that decision
because of my grades I knew that
University now wasn't an option and so I
wanted to stay in education and keep on
learning because learning is one of the
most important things in life you have
to always be learning and
I had some money already and I thought
I'd I'd just go for it I want to be
trained properly
if I'm gonna do this properly because
like I said earlier some people saw it
as just like a little hobby a little
project yeah so if it's going to be more
than a hobby in a project I gotta know
my [__] I've got to be with people who
also know their [__] which is why I
joined the academy because I already had
education before
but one of the big drivers for the
Academy was the network because I just
saw how many people were on it and also
the atmosphere as well because like you
shout at people you'll be like just shut
up and just do it and uh obviously
probably with some more swear words in
there but I loved it because I've played
rugby a lot of my life and I'm used to
competition I love competition which is
why I I join you on the boxing as well
yeah what do you talk about man that was
sick by the way you won that fight I did
yeah so it was fun okay and another
thing is as well as I often say is when
you've invested heavily into yourself it
makes you more investable you've got
experience you've got knowledge you've
got education you've got Network you've
got deals you've got a bit of credit
over the last couple years now big
Network because I'm I'm now
a lot heavier on social media and
there's so my social media strategy is
working quite well for raising JB
finance and I base it on three
principles so it's been known liked and
trusted right so everything I put out
has to fall into those three categories
or it's just pointless right so being
known is just
the consistency of being on somebody's
phone like I have to post x x amount of
times a week otherwise people are going
to forget about me I've got to always
have these amount of stories up
otherwise people just not recognize me
so that's being nice being trusted is
giving people as much value as I can
like I do like little
like informative videos I'll explain the
deals I'll say how people can do this
better that's being trusted because I'm
showing that I know my [__] and then
being light to be liked you've got to be
relatable somebody can't like you if
they can't relate to you which is why
the way I come across on social media is
just me like I'm not putting on the
front I'm not trying to be uh oh I'm a
businessman blah blah blah I'm just I'm
just being me yeah and again it goes
back to when you're calling up landlords
and agents and you've got the the phone
voice I'm super professional hello I'm
just ringing uh from such a company and
and straight away it sounds as you said
it sounds like a sales call and people
generally don't like being sold to so
especially in the UK yeah it's a bit
like not being salty is ingrained in
British culture yeah so just so just
ringing up and just being yourself hey
it's Ben here I'm just calling about
such as the properties it's still
available and just just being chill
weekend as you are and confident that's
very important yeah so talk to me then
about one of the biggest challenges that
you've had what's the what would you say
the biggest struggle that you've had in
your business has been one big challenge
I had was actually when I lost a deal
and so I got an essay I had an essay up
in Liverpool right it was it was really
good it was just for Eurovision as well
and they were renting out like a grander
night so there's so much profit to be
made for that I was like yeah I'll jump
on it I got a JV partner for it we
bought the deal and I went to set it up
but it was all very rushed like really
rushed we woke up at eight went to bed
at like three like every night just just
getting it done it's crazy busy but I I
made the mistake of rushing the contract
and not reading through it properly so I
painted the walls I put wallpaper up I I
drilled into the walls and I also put a
lock box on the outside of the building
but this was a block of flats right so
you can't do that [__] and they just
weren't having it so I got I got kicked
out of the flat why did that happen was
it that you didn't communicate clearly
enough with the land what you were doing
and what the setup was so it was through
an agent but the yeah like you said the
communication just wasn't there yeah I I
wasn't asking the right questions and I
was rushing and the thing is as well the
only thing worse than no deal is a bad
deal right yeah and a bad deal could be
that the numbers don't stack it could be
that you've not communicated it properly
and you're gonna end up wasting time
because it's gonna it's gonna get put
it's gonna fall through yeah what did
you learn from that don't rush be
careful when it comes to taking on deals
and I think especially for people's this
wasn't my first deal but I think four
People's First deals
they're so excited to get going they'll
just take on any deal yeah even if the
breakeven's like I don't know something
crazy like 70 they're like oh I'm sure
we can get lots of bookings so we'll
take it anyway right you you'll just
lose money like in in the winter I was
breaking even and losing I think by 200
quids for both my Studios uh the winds
was really slow and quite a few people
experienced it how do you stop that
happening then how do you do your market
research and determine whether a deal is
going to be good or whether it's going
to be bad you got two main aspects
you've got your location and you've got
your customer generally speaking pretty
much all the cities in the UK can work
for sa but then you also have to look at
how close it is to the city because you
know closer to the city the more demand
it's going to get right so the location
has to be good enough for people to want
to book there then you also have to look
at who's booking am I getting yeah
professionals am I getting contract
answers I might get in families go on
holiday it's like people with I don't
know properties on the Norfolk Coast
they're going to be majority families
going on holiday to the Norfolk Coast
but whereas my Studios I get single
professionals traveling or sometimes to
professionals traveling together and
that will change your business model
because firstly
you need to prepare and set up your
property differently sure professionals
are gonna want it looking very sleek and
clean these families might like it a bit
warmer a bit you know with kids stuff in
you want to put a cot in there if you
see any demographics in your family if
it's going to be business you might want
to put the office desk in there exactly
yeah so you've got to look at your
location you've got to look at who's
staying there
and if the property doesn't work for
that location and if you don't have that
kind of guest visiting then don't take
it what's your main area
Cambridge Cambridge is my area is it
your only area no so I've gone off
Liverpool yeah you've been up Liverpool
yeah funny enough I've been off with
deals in Liverpool
from that area I'm not going back oh
geez but I've got I've actually got a
deal in Plymouth which is miles away but
that's a joint venture and I've got a
joint venture with the same people in
Coventry actually how much money do you
have to put into all these deals
um I had some savings and just money
sitting there for the deals
but for my own deals I think so far I've
raised
about 12 to 15K for my deals personally
so so what's the strategy then like okay
you say you had some some savings just a
joint venture everything because like
for example I've taken on my latest
essay in Cambridge with my own money so
I don't want to start pushing out more
into more deals I I want to have my
personal safety part so I'm not being
financially stupid
and because of social media I've got a
decent pool of JB's I can go to and my
landlord actually so he is your good job
he's obviously seen what I've done and
he wants to make more money have you had
any problems doing joint ventures where
it's not worked out yeah so with the
Liverpool deal was actually a joint
venture yeah and obviously if that was
my own money
oh [__] I've just lost however much but
if it's somebody else's money
[__] like yeah now you got your money
and your reputation yeah exactly and I I
care about my reputation and he was of
obviously
worried that he wasn't going to get his
money back I was
I think it was
seven 8K something like that which for
some people for most people is a lot of
money and I made sure to pay him back
every penny are you a member of pims I
am does that help because a lot of the
business I do is with Academy members
especially looking for deals so if
anything goes wrong I've got that
support which is good in terms of joint
ventures how do you structure it in
terms of do you have to have a joint
venture contract like how are you
structuring it so that it's win-win and
it's safe for everybody so we've got a
joint venture agreement and I get a lot
of people asking about JB's obviously
because I look for them they're like oh
are we gonna make a company and for rent
to rent I think the expense and the just
the hassle of having an extra company
for a property you don't own isn't worth
it every time you do a JV setting up a
new spoilers how do you do it so
there'll be three agreements me with the
landlords yeah as of my company spinning
Property Solutions with the landlords
and then the joint venture agreement
with me and you and then we'll have a
loan agreement as well it's the money's
got to be got to be passed over somehow
yeah and that's the best way in my
opinion to do that safely and securely
how difficult was it learning all of
this stuff and getting your head around
it was it was it really hard was it no
it's quite simple it's just not easy
well like like things can be simple and
hard these can be easy and complicated
if that makes sense the stuff you learn
for it is anybody can wrap their head
head around it like just look at the
Academy we've got 16 year olds to 80
year olds from all corners of the UK
like anybody can learn it it's just you
need to put the time in to learn it like
it's it's not hard when you get the
basics down then you can start
strategizing more like for example with
my essay stuff
I can then start looking at going direct
to companies to try get a contract with
them so whenever they have people coming
over I'm their go-to for corporate
accommodation yeah have you done the
accelerated coaching performance program
how was that that's good that was cool
it was fun it was fun it was I can't
remember exactly how long I got but it
was a good amount of time
you just rinsing me yeah you sit on the
hot seat and we go around and rip you
apart yeah which which is brilliant I
mean some people might not like that but
you need to be able to take criticism to
grow and I thought being in the hot seat
just being rinsed by multi-millionaires
was [__] awesome yeah and also being
able to listen to other people's
problems I remember one of the guys we
had he didn't realize he was a property
millionaire do you remember that like it
happens a lot yeah
I don't realize it yeah and then we go
through the network exactly and they go
oh oh dang I'm actually a millionaire
yeah how old do you reckon you'll be by
the time you're a millionaire
20s 20s is a bit vague though bro that's
not almost 10 years away yeah 29. no I
think I think I want to start buying
next year yeah I want to start because
I'll have enough cash flow by then
to start putting the profits into buying
deals and also I I'll still be going for
JB's so I can buy loads of places with
JB Finance we use the same strategy of
service accommodation but you'll just
buy potentially I would like to do more
developments I think because I've got
the experience I think I could instead
of going up step by step because you
know you've got you got rent to rent you
got
buy to let BR the kind of stages of
difficulty right I I think I can go
straight to developments and you don't
even have to do the whole entire
development you can do planning gain
yeah and the thing is with those types
of strategies is they're slow yeah and a
lot of people like I know that if
somebody like you
um join the academy and I was mentoring
you and you were 19. and you said to me
I want to do property development I want
to buy stuff flip stuff get planning
permission I know that stuff it takes at
least a year yeah before you make a
pound it's like best case scenario
you'll make your first chunk of money in
a year more likely two years so if
you've got like an 18 19 year old trying
to do that and it's so slow yeah and
they're working at Iceland and yeah so
no no let's just make some quick money
now let's just take on some quick Rental
rent have you done any deal selling I'm
not a big fan of deal seven you're not
because I think yeah I know and is that
because you've not done it I have I've
sold one deal
that was co-source I think I made a
grand for that but I think if I'm gonna
put the time into finding deals I may as
well just keep him because I want to
grow a portfolio I want to grow cash
flow that's my aim yeah like some people
will do incredible in in Deal setting so
well like
some of the guys made like 30 Grand in a
month yeah and you see that all the time
crazy it's amazing yeah but I would
rather build the portfolio so I've got
tangible
stuff to go off the cash in the back is
pretty tangible there bro that's very
true that's very true everyone's
different yeah and you've got to find a
strategy that works for you what was it
the Drew to rent to rent then what was
it what was it that really excited you
about that it was controlling a property
without owning it it gives you a lot of
power not having to
put down
50 80 100K for a deposit depending where
you are on the country but still getting
the the profits yeah as a normal
homeowner would right property owner
yeah because if you how much I have Rich
would you say you make on a rent to rent
between
700 in a grams which is more money per
month than an average buy to that
investor would make yeah so you'll make
the cash flow you're making per property
is actually quite High yeah albeit you
don't own it but you control it and also
I think that the experience that you get
like the fact now that you've got so
much experience with staging properties
doing market research dealing with
tenants dealing with guests dealing with
contracts and you're making money how
long was it before you quit Iceland so I
quit and then I got my rental hmos that
was my second deal and you know I was
living at home my expenses were so small
technically I was full-time property
with those two deals right and then I
ended up losing the rental HMO going
down to one deal did you go back to
Iceland no oh good no I I I've got too
much ego for that imagine that imagine
Korean Allison was saying I'm going into
property investment and everyone's like
oh LOL let's see how you get on and then
three minutes later you come back
if I make such a big deal to do
something to go into property full time
I can't fall back myself I've just got
to bite the bullet and everything as
well isn't it like once you've leveled
up and you've hung around millionaires
for a year and you've got some deals and
you're making decent money sure you turn
it over maybe 16 18 Grand but you're
still making a few grand amount of
profit you've got your properties you
can never go back to Iceland no and I
think not only does your job and
financial situation change but your
mentality changes as well right being
being surrounded by people that are so
on their [__] they're so motivated and
smart about business being in any other
environment is just odd yeah because I I
love going to networking events and just
chatting about property because it's fun
and we can relate to it but if I went
back into a normal retail corporate
environment I'd hate it yeah old so the
rest of your life is different as a
result of property 100 which is awesome
what do your family think of what you do
now they like it now do that yeah
because they were skeptical because I
hadn't proven anything at that point
before my first deal it was just a
thought they didn't have any proof the
first deal okay maybe it's getting a bit
more he's getting active but it's not
big yeah but but now I've got a
portfolio now they see me going viewing
million pound houses to do Luxury essays
yeah and you're actually doing the deals
yeah yeah you know what I'd love to come
to one of your properties at some point
and do a video around one of your luxury
houses or apartments like they'll be
sick yeah how many bedrooms is this
latest one two oh the latest I can't say
you can't see how many bedrooms it is
I'm on MDA I can't I can't give too much
is it more than seven
no oh so it's not big it was big it's
just kind of big is it anyway I'll come
down and look at it
yeah maybe do a YouTube video go around
it is it proper luxury you see you've
got like an arcade in there and
everything one of the rooms gonna be
fully games room it's got a TV so I'm
gonna add a PlayStation put a project
screen on a few arcade machines I was
thinking maybe a poke a table but I
don't know biggest thing you learned
over the last year been on the academy
immersing yourself in everything biggest
biggest lesson two things firstly talk
to everyone networking is so important
whether it's for learning raising
Finance getting the deals itself and
secondly don't be afraid to make
mistakes right some people are afraid to
do business because they're worried of
failing
you only fail when you stop I've made
several Mercedes I've lost two deals set
up periods go way over
um what I was planning on I've learned
from a lot of myself have your parents
put your board up yet
how's your age held you back or has it
helped you or is it just not not made
anything I I don't think age matters in
a sense with the individual it doesn't
mean [__] you've got people I especially
now it's so easy to make money like
you've got all the stuff online you've
got crypto people became millionaires
during the you know the big crypto Spike
yeah I would agree with that and I don't
think the marketplace discriminates if
you know what you're doing and you're a
professional and you add value 100 and
you run the right people and you've got
the right Network and the right support
then you're good and that's it Money
Follows value business is the exchange
of value for money so it's as long as
you're on it and have something valuable
to give it doesn't matter what race you
are what sexuality what age where you're
from you can live under a bridge but if
you've got valuable people can buy it
and you're gonna make money and you're
going to move out of that bridge into a
big old mansion
and all sorts going on now exactly cool
well Ben it's been a pleasure working
with you bro thank you for coming on
winners on a Wednesday thank you I know
you dream to come on the show did it
live up to the expectations
appreciate that foreign
[Music]